okay Sara that guy said there's a phone
call I just made a dancer holy [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] happened oh and now I can't do
here oh [ __ ] yeah this is still here
[ __ ] yes why is it smoking so much as
anyone now
that's Andrea music can I get there
yeah that is the way to go oh I don't
know what the [ __ ] ah morning fellas all
personnel is opposed to their
workstations for the day if you expect
to be absent for any reason please
inform your immediate supervisor broken
[ __ ] that [ __ ] I'm gonna quick load the
last step okay I don't know what the
[ __ ] that was about but I haven't any
oven that's for sure
deploying scanning tracking you're
really where are they okay okay I guess
I probably got now look at the hard
stuff morning hello always ineligible
today this case again we expect to be
open for any reason you can form your
immediate supervisor I am finally all a
sec what the [ __ ] where is it
very good place yep okay now time to
[ __ ] around with this stuff
I guess [ __ ] is really happening now a
game is getting a lot harder gonna hack
okay what do I do
0 VAR v 1 okay
[ __ ] this there's really weird [ __ ] done
on air deployed okay there healbot here
that I guess
that's right okay before I do that hold
up okay
you're not gonna like what I have to say
next thing you have to destroy Talos 1
the research that eyghon nothing can
survive including you I know how it
sounds but you've seen what those
creatures can do they're a part of you
now
if even one cell gets back to earth
we're lost okay I'm sorry I wish there
was another way
January can walk you through activating
the self-destruct mechanism alex will
try to stop you
he's allergic to failure too proud to go
back to mom and dad with his tail
between his legs so it's up to you now
good luck told you you wouldn't like it
and I can looks like I'm gonna make a
January bad berry hello Morgan
I'm January 20 35 I'm an operator
there are many operators of word Telos
one but none of them are like me Morgan
I'm your plan B my first task was to
free you from the simulation with you
dead second task was to make sure you
saw your video those are done
interesting new directors are now
available to me
the self-destruct protocol for Talos one
is activated by two arming keys your
brother has the first you had the second
alex destroyed your arming key but you
hit a fabrication plan for a new one in
deep storage that's where you need to go
next we can worry about getting Alex's
key afterwards the typing are spreading
fast Morgan you'll be racing against
them and your brother this key card will
grant you access to the main lift and
all the labs where's the key guard
unfortunately I wasn't able to fix the
lift from here there's another route
through the psychotronic slab Morgan bad
lab is where the type and broke
containment please be careful this is
guys next topic you asked me to provide
you with more neural mods which I've
done
good luck Morgan
a security station in the lobby might
have weapons security station in the
lobby okay I know this way slide stop
spot
I'm taking my loci okay
holy [ __ ] that scared me
sorry did
yeah
ah [ __ ]
Wow okay click load because did you get
love [ __ ] up now your office is
relatively secure come back if you need
to rest or use the fabricator
ah [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
okay looks like we're gonna do a quick
let again because things are turning out
like I hope they would my [ __ ] away
all a [ __ ] what have I done
or is the other one cell division why am
I trying to go
Oh
I hear a [ __ ] is down here I said hey
I like Hyrum there is holy [ __ ]
[Music]
no [ __ ] way yeah yeah [ __ ] add a
bullets I am so [ __ ] now I'm so [ __ ]
I'm so so far yes exports okay thank you
to the boot weapons in the lobby big as
I can a weapon a treasure
[Music]
okay let me say what's the best right
here I need to get the gun lobby
security I got Aurelia skirt it online
I've a connect
so they said Oh
out of my way back okay
and now [ __ ]
I'm in that fucked-up [ __ ] out there
I get in hand just trying to get the
security okay [ __ ] it right out of
health yeah
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
labeled let me now
I hear [ __ ] [ __ ]
I need exclude that
character shades what the [ __ ] of that
now I need like real [ __ ] like where's
the gun
all these are gone they're [ __ ] empty
okay [ __ ] hack this can't baby yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah that you know [ __ ]
easy super very good okay that was not
very helpful
Stella Nam okay now that's fine but I
would just like to get to this [ __ ]
say no one second of and I get into this
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
I chose X write down X and if I can't
dance for emails
oh how do I get out of here
I'd like to get out of here Jesus
right [ __ ] it out it got got got got
got well as our close art this time we
spoke
Michael game this December my purpose is
to help your scheme tell us one by node
remember shot full of holes particular
instructions exactly
well it's a privately pod to copy others
once key in general on divisions along
with the supply to me I'll transmit the
location here man I'll got it to again
in ecology okay I'm getting really
[ __ ] up down this game this time spoke
Michael game this December
my purpose is to help your scene tell us
one by node remembers shot full of holes
tricular instructions of the type in
should break containment now it says
apply to a street pod response as I said
when I they're especially smart I'll
change my location to your map
I'll call it to again
scary some Island shy that got got got
any ice I kept on that yeah it's [ __ ]
up stale Oh what's up [ __ ]
all right there I think so [ __ ] log
down a quick oh [ __ ] that's the only way
to get the [ __ ] out of here
[Music]
huh
Injection station leadership has issues
other work all personnel should report
to muster stations immediately and await
further instructions where is it come on
[ __ ]
Mersey
he's gotta be over there no that's
where is it [ __ ] alright I've left that
fits to hell baby tell me baby [ __ ]
Apple super pair kit oh yes [ __ ] I got
hormones alright yeah two and
[ __ ] everyone that really helps me out
but is it the [ __ ] is that
and also what is it sky-high Pogo and I
really don't want that okay
I catch it back here what is this okay
need that
escape us
yes Dan's getting [ __ ] hard
Jesus how I say
but Ronix is the opposite of safe Morgan
what are you after someone's helping you
looking for my wife's Michaela Eleazar
I can drop on your brother's messages or
an agreement on this one get through
this place fast as possible you're
looking for a maintenance airlock to a
utility tunnel called the gut it'll take
you all the way to the top of the
station bolas okay good
what is that
yeah how do I get out of here now
why do I have to my objectives
[Music]
[ __ ] idea there [ __ ]
the other way to get in there you know
there's some good [ __ ] in there here
those [ __ ] creepy crawlers already
right here
[ __ ] that hallway yet
that's 1/2 minute owls in here come on
okay
[Music]
and I guess this time away to die
psychic dope required beyond this whole
holy [ __ ]
I think for me to [ __ ] eat in here
[ __ ] eat jars on Kara shut a date
house this is
I'll shut down scary psycho scope is
mandatory
psycho scope required beyond this point
here's this guy I don't know what's down
there and I don't like it what the [ __ ]
was that Hayes in there then I can okay
I don't need a trench
all right I guess we're [ __ ] down on
this
why's my house [ __ ] to regenerate
there an are a lot for [ __ ]
engineering
stana
is there a thing where I get like let's
[ __ ] Pakistan says [ __ ] oh the good
[ __ ] is like in a way can I get there
[ __ ] oh great
what [ __ ] get assessed
[ __ ] talk to you [ __ ]
I got nine five Sahana
let's go let's go
apart from neural mods it's the most
important tech on Talos one use it to
scan the type and organisms if you want
to learn what makes them tick you
invented it by the way
okay
three this is this is doctor Calvino
well I suppose you've turned in so
you're ignoring me
I just want to well I will be a little
late for my shift tomorrow but um the
first thing in the morning I want you to
put together a new micro lens array you
see that the old one is it's garbage and
I get what you need from the machine
shop attentive Clive is being an ass
just take it from the supply closet when
he's not looking that we're not supposed
to know - cold butter well I'm sending
it to you anyway [ __ ]
anyway like that here
okay I guess that was that oh I did
[ __ ] sock a blot [ __ ] ever
so I can I'm gonna go require global
point you [ __ ] [ __ ] scanning huh
I'm science primarily Isaac readings of
analyzed data I also provide reference
lookup
what happened to my throw shatner you
probably didn't see me that great all
right Morgan I know I can't make you
stay put but you're gonna die down there
if you don't listen to me
you need to calibrate your second suit
by scanning the Tyson specimens around
you once you get enough scan there the
labs will open more importantly you'll
be able to install - based nor mods
you'll be unstoppable that's what this
is all about Morgan you spent three
years of your life making impossible but
in what they can do given us you've just
forgotten
what the [ __ ]
sending you the code to a second
director calcium's office Oh certainly
certain you're a monster
use them to install one of the typhoon
abilities do that and we can live long
enough for me to see you face required
fascinating Batman
okay - answer
[ __ ] that scared okay oh [ __ ] more
the [ __ ] is telepathy
I'm guessing a save in here
doctor here
any man
they're dead in it
this does not staying safe let's look an
anti rat and weird
okay I can fix that
oh boy I shut the do here [ __ ] that [ __ ]
okay utilities allows blockage I don't
know I need that right now
first contact that
I look at that earth
oh hi
hey Zack yeah get that off me like okay
my dad
is it a loop I can't tell cantaloupe
1965
so [ __ ] is that
what's the dye
oh [ __ ] oh sorry oh
I'm president I up [ __ ] for [ __ ]
John each other pocket okay email what's
it a drink
okay
so apparently she's [ __ ] up that's
[ __ ] now I can bet Morgan a warning if
you scan enough type and organisms
you'll be able to install neuro mods
that are powerful but they're the reason
we're in this mess for one thing the
station's defensive turrets will
identify you as an alien threat there
might be worse consequences I can't yet
see I don't want you to lose yourself
the [ __ ] going on here doctors horse
Dean where are you machine shop I was
messed up but I heard an explosion
forget that grab whatever you can and
get to my office
we're evacuating what what side neural
mods exotic material just hurry meet me
in my office yes sir and bring a glue
gun you got it Sam I made cellmates lice
okay oh no Donna I'll have all this [ __ ]
right
okay you say your say para control what
the [ __ ] is Abdul wait no wasn't there
something that was like oh yeah open
something and Lana
right
Oh tell me know what did you do to my
conference room man what oh oh yes I was
just about to call you all I see is a
dot yes that's right it's the
calibration system for the new touch
screen you only have to run it one time
laughs are you kidding me yep just
follow the dot when it turns green touch
it it should damn it tell vino I do not
have time to play sing along with your
bouncing ball I'll call you back okay I
can attest I got this man in taxes pal
okay yeah
[Applause]
that scared the living [ __ ] out of me
[Music]
oh my god that scared me
[ __ ] it right out [ __ ] horrifying
okay I hated that
hello
it's not graph
hello doctor you think social
psychological potential is at four near
peak level take a good look everything
happening on Telus one started here you
are so driven in the beginning my
mistake was agreeing to put you at the
center of the tests that's when you
began to drift away from me we're close
to understanding what they're after
while they're building just need a
little more time a waiver
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] down we need to talk about
analyse vehicles five exam or what the
[ __ ] is a pin your ass in here where is
it
I was afraid of this
the scientists here were in the middle
of something when they died access to
the gut is closed off during experiments
security protocol you'll have to finish
what they started
back in the 60s and 70s the first
research teams tried to communicate with
the typhoon but this proved impossible
their cerebral structures are highly
developed and intentional but somehow
unapproachable
they have no speech of their own no
language they don't seem to even see us
not like we see ourselves
I mean I'm generalizing when I say us of
course I'm not a person not like you
live exam reseed you're in progress
mogul lockdown in effect until procedure
terminate
much complete nice eh your nephews all
fun thank you click that live back it
down and everybody says well [ __ ] babble
fine
yeah [ __ ]
all right well something tells me I
should not touch that it's crazy I got
an interesting game
I will do quick save
generally less organized
okay going too quick look at this one
that's for sure
boiling examination theatre compromised
[Music]
warning examination being a problem I
generally feel is compromised
Roland examination theater compromised
by chemicals okay get a quick look
because it's getting very we're down
here okay well before I [ __ ] do that
then holy [ __ ] when I go downstairs
complete and a mimics in here fetches
name MX in here that pocket gal refinish
complete
yes there it is spot DFS classic okay I
messed up by that fixed
you know t-carr where's the key card at
Oh
there it's a fun
operator posh
how's that
like this what the [ __ ] is that oh yeah
oh that's it
constructing birthdates servers for
hotline
alright I see that I got good airway I
can get in there
[ __ ]
let's go down here the key card is
somewhere here key card on the ground oh
I guess it really isn't [ __ ] here the
other way to get on there
not okay anyway I'm not really sure what
to do right now let's go I go down
okay well it's clear the [ __ ] go
through here
oil generation either compromised oil
the corner is a theater compromised
[Music]
Foreman a really popular overseas help
ok kakak time' it's an apple jelly deal
sure yes yes Hastings
well it's not again fuller quick to
protect humans features unto things they
don't understand that - killers without
hesitation but it's not because they're
evil
it's because they can't do otherwise you
know what we discovered they lacked
mirror neurons all their wonderful
abilities there's one thing we can do
that they can't empathize with the
suffering and of another living creature
what does they do that
[ __ ] crazy okay huh
Oh
what is that hissing noise
bucket
so let's keep on going
okay I got the blue shot
make it [ __ ] zap
[Music]
[ __ ] that check
hey hey over here
what you need gun ammo I saw one in size
five yeah okay
you get me out of here I'll let you
happy
my name's Aaron Aaron Ingram and and
grammar that is real man now hey what
are you reading a rap sheet huh look I'm
telling you all my mama's grade that is
a stack of lies meant to make pushing
that button easier on you okay fine
listen I want to be honest some of it
probably is true I've done some wrong in
my days but this ain't right now come on
yo got to let me out of here okay let's
say what happened I never did anything
those kids now that's what I'm talking
about some human decency friend now
you're the one person who showed me any
real kindness and you can believe I
won't forget it
see if you still want that code it's
eight seven one four thank you
[Music]
however there now
[Music]
right Linux in here can out now this
little [ __ ] this is all [ __ ] I found
nothing I guess
Wow this is [ __ ] amazing whatever I
said that this guy
listen you running the other fellas
wearing a green jumpsuit watch your ass
playing all these human beings like me
yeah I paid this I'm out man let's go
I don't need to be a nuisance but when
do you think we'll get to that breach I
met it out there as we speak what do you
think happened hard to say it tell her
my eyes on it could be some
micrometeoroids bunch to hold rare but
it happens
hmm okay good hopefully it's just that
is there something you're not telling me
no of course not it's just that storage
room has classified exotic materials we
really can't have it be inaccessible uh
I understand how do you get in
and I said
turn otherway in there
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on and holy
[ __ ] what's my ejected
a lot of no amat can't ii on it sorry
[ __ ] it garyun
Eradicator Auto turns trans stars
last-ditch defense against an outbreak
flimsy but they're easy to fabricate
best part the built-in psycho scope tech
thought they can discriminate between
alien and human targets shouldn't be a
problem for you since you're not an
alien
ah thank you but that's gonna basically
saying that just going to go south right
now scared chicken oh my god gut gut
just what I like the Hat just thought I
like that
okay well I guess it's time okay it's
gonna upset here
that gal Pablo thank y'all for watching
thank y'all for hit that I don't and
I'll see you next time thank ya